Allah herkese Merhabalar Hoş geldiniz
Evet Tamam biz çok güzel neden olması
diyoruz bugün hayallerden bahsedeceğim
hayallerimizi konuşacağız biz Evet
Hepimizin hayalleri hedefleri var ya
gerçekleştirmek için planladığımız
birçok zihnimiz iyice var Bunları
gerçekleştirdiği Hepiniz çok istiyoruz
Ancak çoğu uzun atladı bir şey var
bu başarıya giden yol
bu dümdüz bir yol değil karmaşık
zorluklarla dolu problemlerle dolu
engeller ve başarısızlıklarla dolu
burada başarılı ve sıradan insanların
arasındaki farkı baktığımız zaman
başarısızlığa tepkilerini görebiliyoruz
başarısız daha tepki sıranın insanlar
için sonucuna hayallerine ya da
hedefleri ulaşamadıkları zaman
önemsememek Aslında çok da umursamamak
Ama başarılı insanlar için başarısız
olsalar da bundan yılmadan vazgeçmeden
uğursal umursayarak gidiyor olarak
tekrardan ayağa kalkıp Yollarına devam
etmeleri ile alakalı çok güzel bir sözü
var başarıyı tanımlayan başarılı hiçbir
şekilde Coşku kaybına uğramadan
başarısızlıktan başarısız da hoşuma
yeteneği dönüyor çok önemli bir
kabiliyet şimdi çok güzel göre
ama yine de sormak istiyorum hayalleri
çocukluk hayallerini hala koruyabilen
Kimler var aramızda
bu sayılı çok az Evet hayallerimizi baz
geçmemizi abi engelleyen hiç kokusu var
aslında hayallerimize mani olan
Bunlardan birincisi aslında Çok da
problemli bir şey değil başka yerlere
Yelken açma hayallerinizin peşinden
Koşun Aslında bu çok da problem değil
ancak ikinci sizi hayallerinizden
vazgeçiren ve olumsuz etkileyen en
önemli şey yetişkin tutumları Aslında
yine çocukluktan girerek aynı hayalleri
Taşıyan kişilerin o yetişkinliğe
geçtikten sonraki aşamada Neyi
kaybediyoruz bunu tespit edebilmiş
değiliz ama tamamen realiteyi gerçekliği
ön plana alarak hayallerimizden
hedeflerimizden vazgeçiyoruz
Ben de bugün bahsedeceğim şeylerden
değil ki Hayaller çocukluk hayallerimiz
çocukluk hayallerimiz de yerler var
görünmez olmak neler var uçmak neler var
zamanı durdurmak neler var uzaya gitmek
başka hayallerimiz var düşündüğümüz
zaman sizin Salonu sorsam başka fikirler
bambaşka Hayal gücünüze çocukluğumuzdaki
hayallerinizi anlatırsınız bana şimdi
Evet gün hayal kuran hayaline az video
değiştiren kişilerden bahsedeceğim size
Evet çocuğumuz
en iyi ki hakkını önemseyen okumak
isteyen Bunun için mücadele eden çok
küçük yaşlardan itibaren Ben sadece
kendisi için değil bulunduğu ortamdaki
herkesin okuması için mücadele eden bir
çocuk hüküme yönetim değişti zaman
ülkesindeki üretimin değiştiği zaman bu
Çocukların elinden okuma Hakkı alınan
bir Bunu öğrendiği zaman bir şey de
takma bir isimle
A Blok yazalım ne yok Tanrısı da ismi
İşin olduğu zaman yine aynı Ülke
yönetimi tarafından ölümle tehdit edilen
sonra bir gün otobüsü durdurup başından
ve boynundan vurulan altı ay bilinçsiz
bir şekilde yaşama tutunmaya çalışan ama
bilinçsiz bir şekilde yaşama tutunmaya
Çalışırken o bilinçlendiği 12
yaşındayken mücadele ederek kapı kapı
okul okul gezerek bilinçlendiği He
insanlar yönetimi tavsiye çıkarak
milyonlarca insan ücretsiz ve zorunlu
eğitim yasasının çıkmasından meclisten
çıkmasına sebep olan Bir Çocuk 17
yaşında Nobel Barış Ödülü alan
bu ve dünyanın en yaşlı model ürüne
sahip olan bir çocuğumuz o aynı zamanda
Nobel Barış Ödülü ile aldığı parayı
ülkesindeki yani Partisi andaki Eğitime
Hizmet etmesi açısından okullar
yaptırılması için bağışlayan gece
gönüllü kişi oh malala yusufzay
mi Evet bu çocuğumuz küçüklükten beri
çok komik yani hayalleri Kuran Bir Çocuk
başka hayalleri var Ancak zorluklar
pişmiş bir zaman bırakmıyor çok küçük
yaştayken babası işten çıkarılıyor çok
çok uzun bir dönem havası iş bulamıyor
Onun için ailesine destek olmak amacıyla
uzun süre okuldan sonra 8 saat bir
sürelerde fabrikada çalışıyor Komik yani
hayalinden asla vazgeçmiyor Bununla
ilgili okullara başvuruyor ve alıyor ama
yine yazmıyor azminden hiçbir şey
kaybetmiyor Hatta o beş yaşında ilk
sahnesini alıyor 17 yaşında Okulu ile
beraber götürebileceğin anlayıncaya bu
alanda başarılı olabileceğine inandı
için vazgeçmiyor Oh Jim Carrey
abone ol
mi Evet bu çocuğumuz Aslında Hayata çok
genç yaşta yenik başlıyor çok küçük
yaşta anne ve babasını kaybediyor
var ama bir şeyle beraber yaşıyor maddi
imkânsızlıklar nedeniyle abi soğutmak
istemiyor o kadar az iki Bu ülkenin
cumhurbaşkanının şehrine gelmesini
bekliyor Cumhurbaşkanı şehre geldiği
zaman eğitim aşkını okumak istediğini
onu anlatıyor Cumhurbaşkanı O yanında
götürüyor abisine söylüyor ve onu evlat
ediniyor okul hayatında çok güzel
başarılara imza atıyor ama çocukluğundan
itibaren bir hayali var havacılık
vazgeçmiyor iyi eğitim hayatı boyunca
sıra çeşitli sağlık problemleri ile
karşılaşıyor ve vazgeçmiyor Evet size
havacılık Okulu'na gidiyor birçok özel
eğitim alıyor havacılık alanında birçok
ödüller alıyor ve o dünya onu gökyüzünün
kızı olarak tanıyor ve dünyanın ilk
kadın Savaş pilotu oluyor o Sabiha
Gökçen
mi Evet
o Küçük yaşlarda babasının kamerasını
alarak yönetmenliği hevesleniyor hatta
çok çok küçükken trenlerin çarpıştırmak
çeşitli birimler çekiyor Daha sonrasında
12 yaşlar arasında Arkadaşlarıyla
beraber çeşitli macera filmleri
çekiyorlar ve evinde arkadaşlarına davet
ederek bir ücretle sinema ortamı
hazırlıyorlar ve onları seyret duruyor
birçok okula başvuruyor azminden
vazgeçmiyor bu alanda Güneş benlik
alanında eğitim almak için çabalıyor ama
her seferinde reddediyor vazgeçmiyor
o en son diyor ki bunu para karşılığı
yapmıyorum gibi nasıl istiyorsa gidiyor
ve diyor ki ben bu da staj yapmak
istiyorum staj yapacağım hiçbir ücret
talep etmiyorum ücret talep etmediğini
gören biraz ile uzun görüntüsü ve
çalıştığını gören yöneticiler onu bir
sinek Yönetmenlik veriyorlar Bu
yönetmenliğini çok aşırı olduğunu
görüyorlar Daha sonrasında dünyanın
hasılat rekorları kıran filmlerin
yönetmeni oluyor belki itici Jurassic
Park dersen Bileceksiniz o 4
mi Evet bu kız çocuğu yine çocukluğunda
çok kötü zamanlar geçiriyor annesi
sürekli rahatsız çocukluk döneminde ve
babası ile hiçbir zaman anlaşamıyor
sürekli olumsuzluklar yaşıyor ailesine
yönelik kim geliriz birinde Kim gelecek
hep olumsuz ve özellikle üniversite
zamanında oksfort Üniversitesi'nde
girmeyi çok istiyor bunun hayaliyle
yanıp tutuşuyor ama giremiyor pes
etmiyor efsane Üniversitesi'ne giriyor
Bu da bu zamanda özellikle küçüklük
hayali olan yazarlık yapmak istiyor bir
kitaba başlıyor yazmaya başlıyor daha
sonra üniversiteyi bitirdikten sonra
evleniyor ve bir kız oluyor iyilik
yaşantı istediği gibi gitmiyor ayrı
istismar çok fazla olduğu için eşinden
boşanıyor ve kendini hep babasının o
eleştirdiği şekilde hiçbir şey
başaramayan beceriksiz biri olarak yoğun
için depresyona giriyor intihar ediyor
ama yine de kurtuluyor hayata tutunuyor
terapider alıyor Trap
O da diyor ki Evet bu benim hayalimdi
yazarlık yapacağım yanıp kalan kitabını
tamamlıyor ve dünya üzerinde yazdığı
kitapla bir yerde olan ilk kişi Harry
Potter'ın yazarı Güven ad rolling
mi Evet Bu çocuk çok zor bir yaşantısı
var
Bu okulda işten diyor başarısız olarak
hallediliyor annesi tarafından
okutuluyor şifre Küçük yaşlarda işitme
ile ilgili bir problemi de var ama o
kadar farklı bir bakış açısı var ya
annesi Bunun farkına varıyor ve unu
başka yere taşımaya çalışıyor bunu Grup
cihazını mı icat ediyor Daha sonrasında
Akkor ampulün çok daha böyle verimli
olan çok daha az bir çekim yapan Akkor
ampul üzerinde çalışıyor ve bununla
ilgili olarak çalışmalarını yürütüyor
bunu buluyor
ve Daha sonrasında birçok ödül kazanıyor
beni üzerinde patente sahip Oh Thomas
Edison
mi Evet Ah 8 kardeşi 8 Kardeşli bir
ailenin çocuğu olarak Dünyaya Geliyor
çok küçük bir bölgede yaşıyor Daha
sonrasında ilkokulda daha büyük bir
Büyükşehir'e taşınıyorlar oradaki küçük
yaşadığı şehir şivesiyle konuştuğu için
arkadaşları tarafından dalga alay konusu
oluyor Onun için iki de kapanıyor
sosyalleşemiyor öğretmenleri sonrası
bile konuşmuyor Daha sonrasında o kadar
çok çalışıyor ki beş yaşında okumayı
öğrendiği için çok fazla farklı
çalışmalar yapıyor burada bir sesini
kazanıyor birincilikle bitiriyor ama
küçüklüğünden beri bir hayali var
dışında okumak dışına gitmek buraları
görmek ve eğitimini alırken diyor ki
lisansüstü eğitimde Amerikalı yapacağım
Bununla ilgili çalışmalar yapıyor ve buz
kazanıyor
e-burs Amerika'ya gidiyor yalnız orada
Bizler peşini bırakmıyor arkadaşları
istemiyorlar Onu çok farklı bir bakış
açısı olduğu için başarılı olduğu için
sosyalleşemiyor bir türlü özellikle
danışmanı getirdiği problemler yaşıyor
ve tekrardan ülkesine dönme kararı
alıyor dönüyor tekrar doktorluk
mesleğini yapıyor ama aklı hep yarım
kalan hayalidir sonra tekrardan
Amerika'ya gitmek istiyor Aynı burçta bu
sefer diyorlar ki hayır Amerika bursunu
yarım bırakıp döndüğün için bu sefer
Amerika bu su vermeyiz İngiltere bu su
veririz ama İngiltere'yi kabul etmiyor
borusu yapma pahasına Amerika'ya
gideceğim diyor beş parasız cebinde beş
kuruş parası olmadan Amerika'ya gidiyor
Amerika'da çalışmalar yapıyor Daha
önceki onu tanıyan profesörleri ile
farklı çalışmalara imza atıyor kalacak
yeri olmadığı zamanlarda çoğu zaman
bırak duvarlarda yapıyor Hatta en acıklı
sıb
bu tip Korktun mu Dış oluyor yandım
hortumuyla dış alıyor ama hiç yazmıyor
vazgeçmiyor 400'ün üzerinde bilimsel
makale yazıyor 30'un üzerinde bilimsel
kitap yazıyor ve hücrelerin hasar görmüş
değerini alır üzerindeki etkisine
yönelik çalışmayla Mabel kimya ödülü
kazanıyor Oh Aziz Sancar pil kendisini
vuruyorum
mi Evet bu ailenin
bu iki çocuğundan küçüğü
O kendisi ablamın kardeşi olur iştah
olmaz bir hayalperest ve asil sahildir
yapılan tanırım kendilerini Evet
örnekleri çoğaltmak mümkün videos bir
giydirsin Churchill Michael Jordan
isimleri arttırmamız mümkün ülkemizden
de birçok isim söylememiz mümkün yapılan
bir çalışma var psikoloji profesörü önce
yaptığı bir çalışma Akademi askeri
akademide 14000 başvurunun yapıp
maksimumda 1200 kişinin okula kabul
edildiği bir okulda beş kişiden her
kabul olan beş kişiden birinin okuldan
ayrıldığı sebep sonra buradan ayrıldı
tespit ediyor ve bu çalışmaya en ya da
fırlatıyor ki sebeple acı
15 kişiden bir öğrenci neden bu okul
kaybediyor Bununla ilgili bir çalışma
yürütülüyor ve bunun sebebini nazil
bireydeki azim ve ve dayanıklılığın
yetersizliği olduğu görülüyor
mi Evet aslında Dünya
Ah ah asit ve hayır üzerine kurulu
baktığımız zaman betonu kayayı bu ve ve
asfaltı dönerek çıkan bir bitkinin az
mıyım aynı zamanda baktığımız zaman
hayvanları Nazmi dünyanın bize tüm
canlıların hayalleri ve Azimli üzerine
kurulu olduğunu gösteriyor Bu O zaman
ben diyorum ki Sevgili dostlar
o hayalleriniz de az illerimizde çalışma
şeklinizi imkansızlığı imkansız Kızmak
mı Neden olmasın Teşekkür ederim e